cop feels like I smoked weed my drink
that water my mouth very well
alright I'm 2 Chainz Martin nice to meet
you so what's going on what you got
going on today I'm a thirsty guy I'm a
water some of ye the only waters for me
in America and I think it's nice to
taste some different waters with you
today not really actually because all
the waters coming actually from the same
source it's rain water at one point in a
drip style and different layers all over
the planet and the different layers have
different eras like wine and all the
different waters have different middle
levels and you can measure them by TDS
total dissolved solids the more tds has
a water the more stronger will be the
taste we're starting with a water from
canada work water it's actually fifteen
thousand year old leisure water cost
twenty dollars so might have a little
bit of mammoth sauce in there hopefully
not so I mix it up this [ __ ] like one
oxygen in there water tasters yeah I
have to say I taste like nothing this
water has almost no minerals in it was a
nice glacier water the TDS level is 10
by this water so super super low next
one I've had done before Vichy yeah
that's the number one water in Spain
it's an amazing carbonated water and
this water the TDS level of 3000 I got I
got a question they get the water and
then they carbonate it right it's brand
that does carbonated water Chile this
one is natural company that means the
culmination comes with a spring - yes
gang high water tastes disgusting to me
now afternoon the other one tastes like
Alka Singh machine I'm always saying it
tastes like a nest friend it's like this
often though right healthy for you when
you drink a lot of maybe a hike or
something on your party and then
afterwards you're drinking this you will
not have a headache
so look how much this bar to go for $13
in my restaurant you can't buy it at
like a supermarket that's a tricky part
because I created a water menu in my
restaurant with 20 different mineral
waters took me over two years to get
this water menu starting because in
America you don't have so many different
varieties of water but I have something
for you
there's one more brand what I didn't
discuss this is Beverly Hills 908 oh and
inside here is the most expensive
bottled water so let's see this would
experience cost hundred thousand dollars
because you cannot buy this actually
it's just a made nine times in this
world and this whole experience is the
ultra Diamond luxury collection of
Beverly Hills 9h oh it comes with four
Packer glasses yes what are you paying
one hundred thousand for brother do you
see this it's 14-karat real diamonds
six hundred white ones twenty fifty
black diamonds and white gold and the
whole experience is literally you
getting the case you're getting four
pack or glasses I'm flying out to you it
doesn't matter why on the world I'm more
open this bottle I will do a water
tasting with you as well
two bottles of Beverly Hills 9h to one
with them and turn on with time one this
is our diamond collection then we have
here the Luxury Collection and we have a
blue lifestyle collection as well and a
whole year you're getting actually than
the product that you can refill it it's
a very special water actually in this
bottle because this is the first so many
crafted water in the world that means
they're taking a spring from the
sarahvani mountains and I added
different minerals to it like calcium
potassium silicon all this kind of
minerals tomato extremely healthy and if
the highest
TDS level here in America is still water
about six hundred teen years I think we
should taste it as well because I'm
getting thirsty
it's like fruit that's a cool thing
nothing is flavour it's all natural
minerals with a perfect combination of
minerals super healthy there's good wife
a tasty down and super shiny as well
the most expensive water when you can
just drink rain it almost seems like if
you put a diamond on something they
gonna run up a tab on you
good try more then I'm gonna stay down
with my [ __ ] Aquafina I feed
these smart waters you know what I'm
going with this shout out to my homie
Diplo to both of us have an acquired
expensive taste neither one of us
believing that we should pay $100,000
for bottled water true